walk him to this video playing only X
only X from Turkey yeah 95 here 22 is a
slightly offbeat line but not not really
bad very interesting way to deviate from
main lines yeah is maybe retrying to
play d4 in one move well there seems to
be this seems to be a known porn sack
yeah I can take take twice on d4 but
admittedly it looks risky alternative
would be d5 ok let's go D Phi if I not
to grab this pawn it really looks very
dangerous to grab it
ok this is designed to play the bishop
to a 6 later I'm even thinking about be
five maybe I can go be 5 p.m. but ok
first h6 clarify matters here age six is
useful anyway I don't really know what
Bishop g5 is about very strange play how
does he defend it now f6 it just detect
and cannot be cannot be covered I don't
see how I'd additionally default saying
ok just here I can play not a g4s really
bad here we go I can take d for the
first the first good answer yeah just
take it
if I go Knight takes and he goes Queen
takes g5 yeah the question is I can play
Knight f3 I can go here and back if this
is much simpler Queen takes I'm going to
take here ok f1 maybe look f3 f3 to h3
could be can be a point but I want I
want to play this one night f 59 f 5
will attack the Queen and it needs to
move to a square that allows the trade
and to have the Queen's come off then
I've gained a lot here you know tonight
at five now he is going to take him
never not do that but I can just go to
g3 I hope maybe a three is a good a good
move if he if he does not but even if he
does I'm Brooke t1 now if he attacks the
young I can't play a three year because
Roxy for the screen III and takes online
on deform but this also night at five
obviously yeah this is much easier he
needs to play this and after the trade
I'm going to win the exchange yeah this
is the easiest white resigned yeah yeah
this is too much it's the exchange and I
have the center and two two pawns I
think yeah it's so just a Bishop g5 with
the start of a really ill time plan
the point sack is very interesting i
don't i don't think i should risk that
this kind of position I don't really see
a direct reputation but it feels like
white is gaining lots of time let's say
just for example something like that is
a bit tricky maybe I go back then and
know something like that and it's not so
easy for black to free himself of here
if I want replace something like these
six I need to move the the bishop at
some point well let's say b6 for example
is going to play you five threatening
here and so on this is very very clumsy
position for black so this is probably
the easier way to play i hopes too much
too many moose computer wants to go here
immediately attacking me form and then
queen bee 60 yeah this is not bad at all
yeah it's also good good way to play and
now my idea was to play b5 if he plays
move like that I thought maybe even
really be five Queen takes this Bishop a
six winning next big change and after
that he's in a very naughty pin and he
will lose the Knight to Queen a five
this was my idea but Bishop g5 I think
he just needs to do something else and
maybe even trade only seven but this is
not a means you want to play after that
however I think like it's just winning
really winning this and d4 so weak you
you're never going to keep the porn yeah
Black is just winning here okay thanks
for watching